so initially I had planned to release a
video today about Jonathan Hickman -
east of West but after going through
this series I realized that there are
still some things that I need to flesh
out in order to make sense of the story
and so instead what I want to do here is
make a video on the origin of mutants
and Marvel Comics and what I'm hoping is
that at the end of this you'll have a
solid understanding of their history as
well as why it took so long for Marvel
to provide us with this information
so for a bit of history in the 1960s
when the x-men were originally
introduced Marvel never actually took
the steps to provide us with the source
of mutants and the reason for this is
actually because of DC Comics what I
mean here is that during the 1960s when
Marvel had become the frontrunner for
perfect film and chemical its parent
company who also owned a series of other
publications Marvel had to quite
literally play catch-up by throwing
everything against the wall to see
what's stuck in order to establish
popular characters that could then be
used for syndication as a result with
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby at the helm we
were brought spider-man The Avengers the
Fantastic Four and the x-men among
others as a result of the standard of
character introduction and storytelling
Marvel didn't have time to provide a
comprehensive backstory on mutants and
instead had to create stories that could
bring readers in and keep them here and
so in order to actually make sense of
this what we're going to do is we're
going to jump back and forth between the
publication histories of Marvel Comics
due to the fact the various writers have
covered the continuity of the origin of
mutants and bits and pieces jumping to
uncanny x-men annual number thirteen
from 1989 the earliest depiction of
earth-based life came during the time
when the humans were evolving from apes
told from the perspective of the watcher
during these early days primitive humans
were visited by the Celestials a cosmic
race of beings with vast powers led by
Gaea the mother of four and who for all
intents and purposes was the goddess of
the earth primitive humans were taken
aboard the celestial ship where the
genetic structure was augmented by the
Celestials leading to the formation of
three castes of humanity the Eternals
the deviants and mutants now switching
to 1970 Wood artist Jack Kirby had left
Marvel for DC where he launched the new
gods and the forth world line which saw
the introduction of dark shine because
of creative differences Jack Kirby had
left DC and returned to Marvel in 1976
because Marvel was still in the building
phase of fleshing out storylines and
establishing a foundation for their
mainstay characters in terms of
chronology 1976 was the first time that
we ever saw the Eternals but this story
actually picks up after the events of
uncanny x-men annual number 13
following their genetic manipulation by
the Celestials the deviants went
underground while the eternal state
above-ground as Kirby tells it the
experimentation of the deviants led to
physical deformities and the various
stories of people encounter
fools or monsters are a result of their
exposure to the deviants themselves on
the other hand the Eternals were vastly
powerful and keeping in line with these
themes of good and evil were more on the
order of angels now regarding mutants
where the deviants took to the interior
of the earth and the Eternals took to
the highest mountains humanity stayed on
the surface of the planet but because of
their genetic manipulation by the
Celestials evolved extremely fast with
their metamorphosis in a modern man
taking place over the course of
thousands of years rather than millions
as it normally would have taken at this
point things get a little spotty with
mutants up until 2008 it was an
established concept in Marvel Comics
that apocalypse was the first human to
develop mutant powers some 5000 years
ago
however with Anik Rocher crossover
focusing on the anti-mutant Reverend
William Stryker and his purifiers
attacking the Xavier Institute Mathers
Craig Kyle and Chris Yost established
that a character named Selene had been
the first mutant and was born around
17,000 years ago in Central Europe to
sidetrack for a second Selene was a
long-standing character dating back to
1983 and was created by Chris Claremont
originally her heritage was ambiguous
except to say that she was a sorceress
with ties to externals a group of vastly
powerful mutants who believed they were
immortal with necrosha Chrissie Austin
Craig Kyle gave a nod to the idea that
Selene was a mutant but this didn't
become official until x-force vol 3
issue number 24 what is explicitly
stated that she's a mutant by the
resurrected John proud star now
following the birth of Selene Marvel
leaves us to our own devices to fill in
the gaps on how mutants spread
throughout the earth what I mean here is
that if we assume that the original
humans experimented on by the Celestials
were in Central Europe it would stand to
reason that Selene is a byproduct of
that experimentation using this line of
logic we could make a legitimate
argument that due to human migratory
patterns these humans with Layton mutant
genes would have spread from Europe
leading to the birth of apocalypse
12,000 years after Selene furthermore as
the years passed and technology became
advanced enough to allow for global
exploration these genes would have been
mixed with normal human DNA leading to
the explosion of mutants during the
1950s and the 1960s within the Marvel
Comics and in truth we can actually
trace this theory to its fruition as an
example following the birth of
apocalypse and the emergence of his
powers he had walked the earth for
around forty two hundred years before he
encountered Bennett doop Harry and
twelfth century England while apocalypse
uses access to celestial technology to
wake up Bennett Slayton mutant powers of
telepathy telekinesis and teleportation
leading to his adoption of the name
exodus somewhere around 250 years ago
mystique appeared however because no
actual date was assigned to her birth
it's almost impossible to know exactly
how old she is or when she was born but
continuing along this line of logic
following mystique came Wolverine who
was born in the 1880s as well as name of
the Submariner in the early 1900's
followed by the explosion of mutants in
the 1960s leading up to the current day
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end hope you guys
enjoyed it and I will catch you guys
later peace